the rumors were true overwatch will be
getting in May release and an open beta
for pc xbox one and playstation 4 will
precede the game's launch the beta kicks
off on May 5th and runs until the 9th
but if you want to get in on the action
early you can pre-order overwatch to
start playing on May third and you'll be
able to invite a friend the beta will
let players trout all 21 heroes and it
will include every map that will be
available at launch we want players to
get a feel for the complete overwatch
experience Blizzard said in its
announcement Xbox one players will need
an xbox live gold account in order to
partake in the beta while ps4 users will
not need a PlayStation Plus subscription
to try it out however you will need PS
plus for the retail game like most betas
progress in the beta will not carry over
when the game releases the full game
will launch on May twenty-fourth across
all three platforms for sixty dollars
there's also a forty dollar option for
PC users for more on blizzard's
competitive first person shooter check
out our coverage on gamespot com